on a avec nous Carl Blackburn président
directeur général du Conseil du patronat
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous ce soir
merci de me recevoir alors des
augmentations de plus de 4% l'an
prochain c'est ce que prévoit les
employeurs c'est plus faible que
l'inflation mais c'est quand même
historiquement élevé qu'est-ce qui
explique cette dynamique là qu'est-ce
que c'est l'exercice d'aujourd'hui c'est
la conclusion c'est le forum sur les
prévisions salariales qui est toujours
un événement très couru année après
année qui fait en sorte que les
spécialistes de la question ont fait des
sondages on fait des consultations on
rencontrait des entreprises et ils vont
de la conclusion c'est un contrat fait
en sorte que les prévisions pour les
augmentations salariales pour la
prochaine année on parle de quatre
points 1% ici au Québec ce qui nous met
ce qui nous place en tête de liste dans
l'ensemble des provinces canadiennes
avec le plus haut le plus haute
augmentation salariale qui est prévu
pour 2023
est-ce que les employés ont le gros bout
du bâton en ce moment on parlait tout à
l'heure de pénurie de main d'oeuvre
est-ce que les gens négocient beaucoup
leurs salaires changent d'emploi on
utilise souvent cette cette image de
négociation avec la réalité qui fait en
sorte que 250000 postes sont encore
disponibles au Québec il est clair que
dans ce contexte les employeurs n'ont
pas le gros bout du bâton et les
négociations François qui a
effectivement il y a cette pression à la
hausse sur les salaires mais il y a un
élément qui est impressionnable qui est
intéressant également à considérer parce
que l'augmentation salariale n'est pas
la première des priorités pour les
employés lorsque vient le temps de
négocier leur convention leur condition
de travail c'est beaucoup plus la
flexibilité qui sort en tête de liste si
je peux dire ainsi en termes de
bien-être d'organisation et de
flexibilité à l'intérieur de leur
travail la conciliation famille le
télétravail dans certains cas s'est
rendu maintenant de nouvelles réalités
mais quand même avec l'inflation
l'épicerie coûte tellement plus cher et
il y a il doit y avoir des Rev il est
clair qu'il y a des revendications au
Québec nous avons je pense l'avantage
d'avoir vraiment un dialogue social qui
est en place qui permet autant du côté
travailleurs que du côté employeur de
maintenir des bonnes scènes discussions
et on n'a pas nécessairement des
augmentations de conflits de travail
relié au conscience salariale non alors
il y a vraiment davantage de discussions
qui sont autour des conditions de
travail comme je l'ai mentionné de la
flexibilité mais la pression
inflationniste dans lesquelles on se
retrouve inévitablement à des
conséquences sur le pouvoir d'achat il
est clair que si on prend la photo de
cette année si on regarde l'inflation il
y a un déficit à remarquer pour les la
capacité ou le pouvoir d'achat mais
lorsqu'on regarde sur les 10 dernières
années ben l'augmentation salariale a
toujours été un peu au de ça de
l'inflation ce qui fait que le pouvoir
d'achat sur une plus longue période
généralement il est positif concernant
la réalité des employés quand même vous
attendez vous à ce que les prochaines
nég les conventions collectives qui vont
venir à échéance au cours des prochains
mois ce que ça pourrait mener à plus de
conflits de travail
en lien avec cette réalité parce que
comme je l'ai mentionné le dialogue
social fait partie de notre réalité au
Québec plusieurs provinces canadiennes
nous envie j'oserai dire par rapport à
cette capacité que nous avons ici de
générer cette ce dialogue autour des
certains enjeux et la pénurie de main
d'oeuvre n'a fait pas seulement les
employeurs elle affecte également les
travailleurs dans certains cas ils font
des heures supplémentaires dans certains
cas ils doivent renoncer à des vacances
alors on voit que la réalité dans
laquelle on est nonobstance ceux qui
pensent que la pénurie de main d'oeuvre
c'est une bonne nouvelle c'est loin
d'être une bonne nouvelle pour
l'économique québécoise j'aimerais vous
entendre sur l'immigration vous demandez
80 000 nouveaux immigrants par année on
a entendu monsieur le gouyère maximum 50
000 autrement c'est suicidaire qu'est-ce
qui va arriver si on va pas à 80 000 on
est quand même loin du compte par
rapport à la réclamation souvent que les
chiffres sont têtus en lien avec les
départs à la retraite d'ici 2030 nous
avons besoin de trouver un point 4
millions de travailleurs ceux-ci sont
comblés par 50% des gens qui vont pas
venir de l'éducation donc les jeunes
aujourd'hui aux écoles à l'école vont
combler 50 % des besoins 25% des besoins
eux seront comblés par les gens qui sont
un peu plus loin du marché du travail
22% des besoins eux doivent être comblés
selon les chiffres du gouvernement par
l'immigration et ce chef correspond à
64000 ce qu'on a fait au conseil du
patron de Québec dans les dernières
semaines on a pris le manque à gagner
des dernières années on l'a simplement
ajouté sur les prochaines pour s'assurer
qu'on puisse collectivement réussir à
remplacer un point 4 millions de
travailleurs ce qui fait que le seuil
auquel on devrait s'attendre
correspondant aux besoins du marché
devra être de 80 000 émigrants par année
mais quand même augmenter le seuil
d'immigration ça met de la pression sur
plusieurs aspects de l'économie entre
autres le logement c'est difficile aussi
de les attirer en région comment est-ce
que vous voudriez régler ça quand même
d'abord la situation de la
difficulté de trouver des logements les
problèmes en place de garderie ou les
problèmes à l'école ou dans les hôpitaux
n'est pas lié à l'immigration c'est une
réalité qui nous affecte tous
aujourd'hui l'accueil de travailleurs
immigrants supplémentaire ça vient aider
le Québec à continuer d'avoir sa
prospérité la meilleure façon d'aider
les gens à s'intégrer ces viols travail
lorsqu'on regarde par exemple que 80% de
l'immigration économique par le français
donc l'immigration n'est pas une menace
pour notre langue au contraire alors il
est important de faire attention je
dirais aux enflures verbales que nous
apporte la campagne électorale
concernant l'enjeu de l'immigration
c'est un sujet qui est trop important
pour qu'on puisse escamoter toute
discussion possible autour de slogan ou
de camp publicitaire et moi je pense que
comme société au Conseil du patronat on
pense que comme société on se doit de
faire ce débat sereinement et les
besoins de notre société si on veut
construire à prospérer et accroître
doivent inclure l'immigration dans
celle-ci et dans ce contexte il est
clair que la pénurie actuelle de main
d'oeuvre la courbe démographique de
population qui est plus vieille
nécessite de faire ça débat sereinement
et encore une fois faut éviter de faire
des enflures verbales qui ne donneraient
merci beaucoup monsieur blackborn
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI